The planet has been taken father.
The Third Eyed King pledges eternal loyalty
to your cause.
He accepted my terms?
Eventually.
Well done daughter.
Well done.
Stop it!
Why?
By the look of it you seem content enough
at the time.
I was a prisoner.
You were a warrior.
I didn't ask for it.
You didn't refuse.
After my planet died I had nothing, no one.
And I thought I never would.
And I was alright with that, I had a new vocation.
Then I found you.
And at my side you became the fiercest woman
in the galaxy.
That's why I chose you to find the Soul Stone.
I'm sorry I disappointed you.
I am disappointed, not because you didn't
find it.
But because you did and you lied.
I don't know what you're talking...
I gave you my trust!
You repaid it with deceit!
At least be honest about it now.
I could make you tell me.
You seem to know that.
I never wanted to force you into anything
That's why when you left me all those years
ago I allowed it.
You allowed it?
You haven't been under the impression that
you escaped?
Daughter I raised us you smarter than that.
I'm not your daughter, you didn't raise me
you kidnapped me, orphaned me and imprisoned
me!
Everything I hate about myself comes from
you.
I stayed because you taught me I didn't deserve
better.
Why did you leave?
Because I found people that showed me I did.
You had a family here little one.
No I dind't.
Yes.
No.
You just didn't care what happened to it.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here.
With the Infinity War Blu-ray release we're
finally getting to see the movie's deleted
scenes and the one you just saw is one of
the things that the Russos were referring
to when they said there was more backstory
for Thanos that got the chop from the finished
film.
This deleted scene takes place in the throne
room on Thanos's Sanctuary ship, and would
have occurred after Thanos took Gamora from
the Guardians, having tricked them with the
Reality Stone on Knowhere.
OK let's look in more detail at some interesting
points in the deleted scene.
Notice that red flash there, well that's Thanos
using the Reality Stone to create a flashback
of sorts to remind Gamora what her life was
like with him.
We get to see Gamora acting as one Thanos's
enforcers, exacting tributes from rulers.
She even brings him the head of a king who
presumably wouldn't acquiesce to Thanos's
demands.
Gamora and Thanos's feelings about their shared
history are diametrically opposed.
He sees Gamora as having become a warrior
thanks to him and she sees herself as having
been his prisoner.
Remember the actual movie only shows us Gamora
as a young child with Thanos.
So this moment in the deleted scene is an
interesting bit of "show-rather-than-tell"
backstory for her character.
As well as Thanos's warped view of their relationship,
the deleted scene also confirms how much he
views Gamora as his favourite daughter saying
that by his side she became the fiercest woman
in the galaxy.
We've seen and heard about this favouritism
before in the Guardians films and how painful
it was for Gamora's adoptive sister Nebula.
That's why I trusted you to find the Soul
Stone.
I'm sorry I disappointed you.
I am disappointed, not because you didn't
find it.
But because you did and you lied.
The beginning of the exchange between Thanos
and Gamora about the Soul Stone is almost
exactly the same in the deleted scene as it
is in the final movie.
That's why I chose you to find the Soul Stone.
I'm sorry I disappointed you.
I am disappointed, not because you didn't
find it.
But because you did and you lied.
However, after Thanos reveals that Gamora
lied to him about the Soul Stone, the deleted
scene continues with further details whereas
the final movie cuts immediately to Nebula
being tortured.
In this extended part of the deleted scene,
Thanos reveals that when Gamora left him back
in the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie,
she didn't escape as she believed, instead,
he allowed her to leave.
Gamora's reaction to Thanos calling her daughter
is basically the same as, but a bit longer
than, the version in the final film.
Daughter I raised us you smarter than that.
I'm not your daughter, you didn't raise me
you kidnapped me, orphaned me and imprisoned
me!
Everything I hate about myself comes from
you.
For a time you had that same will.
As you fought by my side daughter.
I'm not your daughter.
Everything I hate about myself you taught
me.
The deleted scene ends differently with Thanos
portalling to where he's holding Nebula prisoner,
rather than opening a huge door as happens
in the actual movie.
When you compare this deleted scene to what
we saw in the final film, it actually feels
more like an alternate or extended scene than
a truly deleted scene.
The scene in the movie had a much more dramatic
opening with Gamora tossing the food her father
brings her against his throne which immediately
and clearly reinforces the antagonism between
father and daughter.
The deleted scene also doesn't include the
moment where Thanos tells Gamora how her planet
is thriving ever since he killed half its
population.
We were happy on my home planet.
Going to bed hungry?
Scrounging for scraps?
Your planet was on the brink of collapse.
I'm the one who stopped that.
You know what's happened since then?
The children born have known nothing but full
bellies and clear skies.
It's a paradise.
Because you murdered half the planet.
A small price to pay for salvation.
You're insane.
That's an important character moment for Thanos
as it shows the twisted logic he's constructed
for himself to justify his plan for the universe.
And, of course, it's also an important piece
of exposition for the audience to understand
better what Thanos has in mind later when
he snaps his fingers and turns half of humanity
to dust.
So, although I think that bit of extra backstory
for Gamora would have also been interesting
to see in the movie, overall, the final version
we got was definitely more dramatic, snappier
and worked better.
It was also a bit shorter which I imagine
was another consideration for the Russo Brothers
given Infinity War's already long runtime.
By the way, originally, there were more Thanos
backstory scenes in an earlier Infinity War
script.
According to the screenwriters, a scene was
cut which showed how Thanos was rejected by
his own people on his home planet of Titan.
And another scene was chopped which showed
how the Mad Titan recruited the Black Order.
So, what do you think about this bonus Thanos
and Gamora scene?
Would you like to have seen it in the movie?
I'd love to hear your thoughts in the comments
below.
Tap left to watch deleted scenes from Ant-Man
and the Wasp or tap right for my full Marvel
movies playlist.
Congratulations to my Ant-Man And The Wasp
giveaway winner.
Send me an email with your details so I can
get your prize out to you.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!